coming up inside
still have smile
he's punching into the front side so my
hand is kind of coming up okay so I
comes up my body yield so I kind of
meeting him and then look yield the
space the home yield we do the other
side
oh don't stay here and move him move you
don't move him move you here
well you come out to meet them wherever
you're at it doesn't bother me that you
can yield you then you're stuck here
you're stuck you see you've got your
stick okay so don't push him away don't
let one side then engage yield
a little warm
[Music]
so you cannot expect to be on them it's
hard to get on the outside where all the
guys celebrate that angle it's hard you
know so I'm here now I can get to the
other side so I need to know how to go
to the outside
so don't go like this and he can help by
closing it off
nope this angle that I want to go
next you're not gonna go here so what I
have to do is to keep him thinking and
he's gonna get that you see that and
then just close off that corner you see
how I did that that's all I'm asking of
the technique I'm not allowed to put so
much then as you see boom that's it done
okay so don't start doing this as I said
just here
Oh buddy okay and then yield yield
[Music]
this way
as you watch then I use maneuver the
cowboy with him
okay so what I'm ready to do go slower
and I'll move the back foot so let's
just focus on the front half
understanding let's do it first we're
gonna move him my hats here on the
center line and then Wow and that's it
he's off and then boom boom II not yet
boom back in the Garter line I knew it
two more times one one two
okay let's go back with step okay you're
trying to learn a cookie ID name is oh
okay the easiest way to learn that is to
assign yourself begin reconciliation
okay which means that I have to sign him
the young horse say check okay the young
horse is demonstrated with a spinal
displacement I don't walk here even if I
need a water that's not what I do I
don't do that in training in
if I'm living a moral life my attacker
is not going to attack me like that
that's a sport attack okay this person
wants to get me it's going to be what we
call a social violence not social
violence and they're going to want to
practice territoriality they're going to
want the space that I want so they will
engage we demonstrate that any social
violence with smile on this placement
I'm going to scan where he's standing so
I never go like this you see that's
sitting out here okay so I have to drill
and I doubt just a straight line I can't
go undeath why Bonnie
you can see try now on the space that he
was standing on so in the drill I'm
going to be you can I don't know like
this I push through he doesn't release
watch my front foot if you're not sure
what to pay attention to my front foot
moves my front foot does not stay still
okay let's go here is everything and I'm
doing an EVP no I am NOT going like this
this energy is curdling now there's
space
don't go from here to that side you see
that your elbow comes to this spot where
this hand is down so imagine this is
face and my elbow goes there then the
hackers don't move your feet we're
simplifying it here
my elbow goes there how does it go there
with the db9 Oh what does he give me
nothing
don't flap extension extension basic
okay deal you all felt that when I get
about here all these there's a lot of
weight on there okay
so what we did is we continued to move
him into that hidden space but this time
we're going to move myself into the in
space at the back one
so rather than moving him into that in
space I with myself into when do I do it
when you felt that at all others the
weight okay come on whoa there's his
weight come off of it and finished
Shh I wish
so we're here like that you see where
I'm ah okay
can you see what I'm doing I'm not Karen
I'm not on a forward angle there is an
Ikea teacher than that you see and so he
ends up pushing me versus you guys are
kind of various okay so as like as I
roll around I'm gonna be here but okay
same thing there's ID adhesion in there
I'm not stopping him
I'm just glued underneath you see so he
I connect that to my Center and he
pushes me let's see you push the slide
you just have enough in the technique
anymore okay I love this any wishes move
with me it's just anything we're doing
here whoa and so when I'm ready
I let him push what happened this thing
I tend to be and we're stuck down with
the idea teacher we're stuck we're stuck
we're stuck we're stuck okay
and I am deciding I'm going to
that would be stuff over here well we're
stuck that's it
stuck a winner so the worst thing to do
is be on the depression but same thing
with positive pressure no relax contact
you want contact and then you reuse it
orange
it's the second punch I want now you're
gonna rotate you can just get your feet
there you go then
but no pauses so boom here comes you
know that's not that's like a body but
you have to do this physics stick stick
stick inside you stood you'll be me
[Music]
always it's just good people don't let
you do it that way because they try to
help he'll move so like when I go like
that he'll cover on push me in the face
oh do you understand
so what he said it kind of looks like
that I didn't point to be the face he's
never going to get there and then I'm
I'm not doing a turning of the wheel his
his body's coming in we'll get to this
part right I'm here in here you see
there's the tail you see the tail and
then in the projection whoa I'm not
turning the wheel he turned the wheel
people hold on this top you can tilt and
you for Jack then and so stick won't
stick
tilt back
don't be turning in sick wool you are
ten so I'm going to start doing it more
with sticky I can stop myself
he can do whatever he wants right stick
stick stick there's the tail try not to
get here
do you see a nut punch again in the face
oh nice you're stinky but you're nothing
if you were stinky you would move up
there whoa boom right here in the chips
and the progenitor okay go slow
[Music]
okay so kind of like you know you can do
your side Mountain States and why not
when I'm here like that he's gonna bring
a rock I go without you
that's why we have like issues I'm not
good dependent